breaking news supreme court overturns
roe versus wade this has been the law of
the land
for probably 50 years i want to say is
this the vt valuetainment.com article
scroll in a little bit so the supreme
court has overturned roe vs wade ending
50 years of federal abortion rights the
supreme court has officially overturned
roe vs wade giving individual states the
power to limit ban or allow
abortion all together a couple more
details for you just as samuel alito
wrote in the court's opinion we end this
opinion where we began abortion presents
a profound moral question the
constitution does not prohibit the
citizens of each state
highlighting each state from regulating
or prohibiting abortion row and casey
arrogated
that authority we now overrule those
decisions and return that authority to
the people and their elected
representatives it is now going back to
the states this is a big deal
i'm sure there's a lot of ladies very
not happy about this male feminist not a
lot happy about this people who are
um pro-life very happy about this people
who are pro-choice not so happy this has
been one of the most contentious issues
in the country for years this will be on
the ballot box called midterms in 2022.
culture wars are a real thing the left
has been what i would say dropping the
ball on some of the critical race theory
stuff on the woke type stuff on the
transgender type of stuff
has the right
the right side now dropped the ball on
losing the female
vote
come 2022 and 2024. donovan let's start
with you sir
wow this is uh this is a tough one man
um one thing that i will say is that
people on both sides of the argument
there are there are people on both sides
the pro-life and then the pro-choice
it's a lot of times you can just tell by
the way they speak it's not even about
the issue it's really just about pissing
the opponent off a lot of people you i
mean you've seen i mean you see uh you
know rallies where people are yelling at
each other what gets lost in translation
is what's actually at play people are
just disagreeing with people they do not
like that that's the first thing the
second thing i'll say i'm not a
religious i'm not as religious as i used
to be but there is no way that you can
condone killing people before they're
born and i'll and i'll actually i'll
give you an analogy if we found out that
there was some veteran that there was
some veterinary hospital in wisconsin
that was aborting kittens and puppies
before they were born the world would
stop that there would they would be
picketing outside they would pick it
outside oh we have to bring this person
to justice yet we can kill people before
they're born we and it's interesting we
we talk about people valuing themselves
but it appears that people value they
value the lives of animals which are
important but they value the lives of
animals before people there are there
are animal cruelty statutes and laws
but people can people can willfully and
the whole my body my choice thing that's
[ __ ] since when do we own our
children adam since when does the baby
and
that baby does not you do not own that
child that is that that is that baby's
body you are making a decision
unilaterally to end the life of someone
else who didn't even have a say so i
don't base this on any religious on any
religious context i just think that
killing people before they're born
should be illegal would you do me a
favor kelly because i want to get the
lady's opinion on this pull up google
states abortions timeline let's pull
that up and we'll go from there janita
would you like to go
yeah sure uh yeah i i looked at this
today and i actually had a conversation
because
i don't feel like like okay i have four
kids everybody know that okay
beautiful kids my oldest is 21. okay and
by the way can i can i can i can i blow
people's minds
the 21 year old has a kid janine is a
grandma actually my 18 year old
so no i i never had an abortion right
but when it comes to i can't believe
you're a [ __ ] grandma we got it guys
the show's up that's incredible that's
incredible
but when it comes to um
uh having a choice or having an option
i don't feel like it should be in the
the hands of any representative or state
of any kind think about it like this
there are
uh
communities or neighborhoods whatever
that especially the impoverished ones
don't always have access to health care
or
contraceptives you know that just it's
not there and the education on it is not
there so
what do they do
they go out and [ __ ] have babies
or they they do this thing get pregnant
try to fix the problem oh god i can't
take care of this kid i can't i'm not
this is not gonna work there's no way
like i'm gonna have to drop out of
school they don't have the support like
other communities and other
um
cultures have
and then they end up with a bunch of
kids they can't afford on welfare
in the project somewhere staying
impoverished and then what happens to
their kids
they continue that same cycle you think
it's a vicious cycle it goes on very
very much by the way just just to add by
the way i don't know if you want to pull
this article up real quick about how
much it costs to raise a kid and then
we'll get to devin's thoughts on a lot
okay so uh
article right here raising a middle
class child will likely cost almost 286
thousand dollars that's from the age of
zero to 18. the cost of a child was
about 240 250 000 prior to
inflation but inflation is affecting
kids too now it's closer to 286. so uh
to have or to not to have kids is a
financial question it's not just a
biological question
food clothing shelter little league
ballet designer jeans
uh proms cars uh potentially paying for
college all part of the long list of
child related expenses these don't
occlude when the kid when the offspring
who have uh already left the nest or
sometimes they won't even leave the nest
a lot of gen z and a lot of millennials
at home so how should modern americans
even address this devin do you want to
weigh in on the abortion issue issue and
the cost of having kids i mean my
thoughts are pretty simple on this topic
um
abortion has
no place as a method of birth control
women who use abortion as a backup form
of birth control meaning they're not
using any type of protection and they're
saying it's okay i'll just take a plan b
or i'll just do this i'll deal with it
after the fact no if you're mature
enough to have sex especially
unprotected sex you're mature enough to
know your contraceptive options and you
have to know what the consequences are
for your actions um just because it's
expensive to raise a kid doesn't mean
it's okay to kill it
i think i think
rollo calls it uh hypergamy at its
finest personified yes if you're gonna
get knocked up by a a-list dude a
high-value man
but if you go and get drunk and get
smashed out by some you know
fugly schmuck
you're probably gonna have an abortion
on dinner though right is this gonna
change the way that men and women think
though oh man
unfortunately it's gonna make things
worse you think it's gonna make things
yeah
i agree
because at the end of the day this is
not to stop what it's going to do
rip okay so if you think about it
remember like back
in the like okay around the 50s 40s and
50s you know what i'm saying
these young girls scared you know they
done had sex
found out they're pregnant can't tell
their parents
and you know that was a big deal you
know or whatever so you go and you find
a person like these guys
that they're doing the same thing
you understand me and so this is gonna
become more of a practice so now the
witch doctors is coming back
and halfway killing people now you can't
never have no kids okay if you even make
it out of there
and it's gonna be young girls doing this
that's right yeah i think it's a shame
that we know more about having sex than
contraceptive i'm talking about
education this is the problem because if
you're gonna do this and make this a
thing where you're like oh well um you
can't have an abortion after xyz then
make sure that you put in the same
implementing the same things and making
sure you educate these people and giving
them
what the tools that they need birth
control should be free i thought it was
no it is not well what about condoms
what you can't afford what people can't
afford seven bucks for a condom they
break
that is not that no birth control is not
free either is um
uh condoms fifty dollars and condoms
ain't freezing okay by the way if you
ever go to a cvs or a walgreens they
lock up condoms they don't hello
but here's the thing so now we have an
unwanted pregnancy because of the
failure of a contraception it happens so
now we gotta punish the kid oh my condom
broke so now we're going to end the life
of another human to say that punishing
that child is not bringing them into a
world that you're not prepared for you
can't that's not them that's not no
that's not that's not our call to make a
lot of is the person who's having that
baby called to make no you know what you
can and you cannot do but the baby
doesn't know the baby doesn't know what
they can or can't do a person does so
are you gonna ruin their life because
you're not already gonna do it oh so so
you're going to end the life of somebody
before they even have a chance to get
out into the world that's awesome let me
ask you guys a question let me ask you
guys a question don't have sex and i'm
gonna get to kelly too let me ask you
guys a question
um
should women
have a
larger voice
in this argument meaning
ever you know
you know how many politicians are meant
probably 80 yep
should women have a larger voice in this
controversy
meaning like i'm not i don't know how to
gauge that yeah but like one time on pbd
podcast i was like
listen let the ladies decide and let's
see what they have to say what do you
mean they'll let the ladies side the men
will be about like
should women have a larger role in this
i do feel that way men don't have babies
that's what i'm asking they help create
them but they don't have they don't
sacrifice
careers for them they don't do any of
that right
devin should women have a larger voice
i'm not saying men don't have a voice
but should men like if it was a 4-4 vote
and like we need to have a fifth vote
let the lady decide that's what i'm
asking
because i think it was a six three
supreme court
i mean it takes two to tango and if if
i have an abortion and my husband
doesn't know it
okay is that okay no that's different
we're not talking about it okay
when is it when is it that happened to
me before straight up right and what is
it okay so a girl had an abortion i have
no idea this was 15 years ago i would
have i would probably have a
teacher right now adam junior right i
mean she told me after the fact i don't
even know what i would have done 15
years ago on the same token there's uh
how many men out there that are paying
child support for children that aren't
aren't his
no so we have are you kidding me you
said none don't they have to have dna
tests oh my god listen i'm gonna i'm
gonna do it
i'm gonna quote a very famous poet he
said this
18 years oh gosh 18 years and you find
out that the kid ain't yours the country
kelly what are your thoughts on this i
know that you've been sort of deflecting
answers but i know you have an opinion
on this i'm not deflecting answers i
just don't choose to look at people
in that you're not given a score
yeah your thoughts on the new supreme
court overruling they didn't ban
abortion they gave the people the power
to vote in their states correct what
they believe in so if you're a religious
person and you don't believe in and and
you don't believe in killing a
a baby
then you're you're gonna go vote for
your representative who's then gonna
make a law that says abortion is illegal
except in
cases of you know health or whatever
south of the world yes of course
by the way um i found something that was
some sort of list it kind of just uh
highlights everything i'll read that
continue religious you don't have to be
religious to be people i agree yeah
right so
that too and then if you don't then if
you need a abortion like there has to be
the the reason that roe vs wade was
overturned is because our constitution
does not have anything in it that says
it's illegal so that's why it was
overturned
if there needs to be a new law then yes
women especially but everybody needs to
vote and uh make laws that actually
stand up in court roe versus wade wasn't
standing up because it's not in our
constitution it was case law that's
really what happened yeah so
uh it's and i think it is unfortunate
because now
like the country's in like political
turmoil we have to go through all this
and elections coming up so both sides
are going to use this to their advantage
and it's going to muddy the waters about
who we should well let me pose a
question where does the my body my
choice come into this because that's
been a whole thing with abortions
started when you had sex with everything
like that your choice started when you
had sex there it is that's right if you
look man we understand contraception
fails and this and that but everybody
knows how maybe how babies are made and
when it comes down to it i could not
agree more it and again we don't own
like we don't own our kids your kid's
body does not belong to you yes they do
janita you said something you believe
that they do hell yeah because that's
what the damn police will tell you if i
beat our ass and sit outside and put out
my house now that's your baby you gotta
take care of it
but those are the ones
well those are the laws of the land
we're talking about the laws of nature
you don't own this is why slavery was
outlawed because you're not supposed to
own other people right but it's a long
long ass time so i'm still waiting well
the point the point is is that if it's
illegal for slave owners to own slaves
as it should be then it should be
illegal for women to make unilateral
decisions about people they don't own
they didn't give birth to them wait hold
on that okay these are these are two
different arguments they are
they're they're two different arguments
but men sacrifice too when it comes to
when it comes to kids not all men do
because i know a lot of people ain't got
no daddy around here and they gotta
figure it out okay now we're mutting the
waters the point that i'm trying to make
here women decide which babies are born
and which art should women have more of
a voice women already have the voice it
really is their choice no matter what i
say if a woman chooses to get an
abortion there's nothing i can do about
it because it is her choice my
contention is that is that it shouldn't
be and it's funny because when it comes
to my body my choice when a woman
decides to have an abortion my body my
choice but when she carries the kid to
term now she wants dad involved so which
is it you understand what i mean my body
my choice my wallet my choice that's
that's one of the that's one of the
other ones one of the concepts that are
sort of skewed in this damn kelly final
word janita made a great point earlier
today about how you know if you're in a
if you're in a impoverished city or
whatever these things are more likely to
happen
the question shouldn't be about a law
against abortion
i mean it should be illegal to kill
someone but the focus should be laws on
sex education access to contraception
access to a medical doctor that can help
you if something serious happened those
are the conversations that we should be
having and voting for when we vote for
our representatives rather than just
there's
a roe versus wade was a band-aid and it
wasn't a good one so now is the time for
everybody to vote
and make their voices in your particular
state do you think the sex contraception
industry is if this i'm not a conspiracy
guy but the fact that contraception and
birth control is not as widely available
as sexual accesses do you think this is
by design for economic reasons because a
lot of people probably argue they do
yeah i definitely do depending on what
area you are in abortion doctors are in
business
all of that if you if you go uh fort
lauderdale like a little bit east like
in the hood area
you can find at least two
abortion clinics you understand me right
there but but there's no doctor's office
unbelievable okay there's no
i don't even think it's a walgreens
that's a problem you understand so so
where are they getting this stuff from
they they want to take away sex
education they ain't even really
teaching it in some of these schools
they learn from music videos
and that's not helping so what are we
doing so you're not educating them but
you but you don't want them to fix a
mistake that they may make okay i
understand
it's not right to kill anybody sure but
educate them and give them the resources
i agree period i agree here's some final
stats for you before we move on all
right so here are some of the highlights
that you guys should be aware of uh
regarding roe vs wade and access to
abortions now that is going to the
state's highlights 44 states prohibit
some abortions after a certain point in
pregnancy after a certain amount of
weeks nine states ban abortion straight
up one state bans abortion at 20 weeks
um 10 states ban abortion at 22 weeks
five states ban abortion at 24 weeks 18
stands states impose a ban
at viability and one state imposes a ban
in the third
trimester ladies and gentlemen
if you're having sex and you're worried
about having kids look up your state
laws and regulations
your state legislative body
your state legislative body now controls
your body
[Music]